go ahead Sammy you Muslim yes
alhamdulillah oh for man welcome though
W welcome to the panel can you prove to
me that Jesus is a is the Messiah man
yeah I was hearing your conversation
with the other guy that's the type of
proof you're looking for that and the
type of proof that I believe in it's not
proof for you for us Quran is the proof
I understand when you make that type of
statement what type of proof you ask
expect a Muslim to give you you don't
believe in that well let me all right so
let me let me do this using the Quran
I'll let you use the Quran the Quran can
be some proof today if it has this if it
has justification for how Jesus is the
Messiah so according to the Quran what
is the mission of the Messiah just like
any other messenger I don't I wouldn't
be able to give you an exact answer
right now because I don't have the Quran
in front of me but it's just a title
according to Islam a messiah is a title
you know like Prophet ibraim Alam he's
the and then so every Prophet they have
a certain title that's just a God's love
being being shown to that one particular
person what do what does it mean to be
the friend friend of Allah what does it
what does it mean to be the Messiah even
Jesus to us is also a even Muhammad is
also doesn't say that about about Jesus
or or Muhammad I think there's a Hadith
that says that about Muhammad though but
not not a Quran verse what does it mean
to be Messiah though bro so we we know
what it means to be KH Allah means a
friend of Allah what does it mean to be
the messiah messiah means to be cleansed
to be clean and then to be appointed to
be cleansed yeah what to be cleansed
cleansed of what of sin so the Messiah
is free from sin in essence every
Prophet is you know that's one well no
no Muhammad has sinned every human being
has sinned except except the Messiah
right the Messiah is cleansed of all
sins every human being is a sinner it's
understandable you know but prophets are
believe for us to be innocent they would
not sin knowingly they could sin
mistakenly but they will not sin
knowingly so not so they're not free
from sin exactly but is Jesus free from
sin inal sin you know yeah is Jesus free
from sin as a prophet just like period
he's every Prophet is a human being is
Jesus free from sin my brother my belief
would tell me yes he is okay so Jesus is
completely sinless of intentional sin
yeah of any sin being sinless means that
you have no sins whether intentional or
unintentional you're sinless you're
without sin and that's also the same
belief as Muslim we have for all the
other prophets too so it doesn't really
make any big difference for me all right
so just to be clear just to be clear
Sammy you believe that Jesus is sinless
right as far as my understanding is yes
we believe the same other prophets all
right in the Quran you have Allah
telling Muhammad to repent of his sins
in the past and that Allah is going to
forgive his sins of the past and the
future yeah that's a very big part of
our religion to always be seeking
forgiveness you're missing the point you
know there's a no Brother Sam you're
missing the you're right so showing that
Muhammad sins and then asks for
forgiveness at least 100 times a day
right the way I look at it is the
prophet's role is to be the role model
for humankind stop brother Sammy Sammy
Sammy Sammy Sammy I need you to I need
you to focus on the conversation okay I
am okay so the point the point the point
the point here Sammy is that Muhammad is
not sinless he's full of sin and he asks
for forgiveness correct yes yeah he asks
for forgiveness yes while Jesus is
sinless and never asks for forgiveness
because he's sinless he has nothing to
ask for forgiveness for that that that
statement that you're making I don't
know about that you just said you you
said he was sinless earlier you just
took like one I said you asked me what a
messiah is you know so I from what I
know Messiah is somebody appointed
someone who's blessed someone who's
cleansed and cleans cleansed of what of
sin you know all right you know so
that's you're focusing only on one part
well I'm FOC yeah yeah I'm focusing on
one part that's really important you
have Jesus who's the messiah who is who
is sinless but you have Sam Sammy come
on brother I know you hear me talking
bro come on I do okay so don't talk
don't try to talk over me this won't
won't go well so you have Jesus
according to what you said earlier
hopefully you don't backtrack you said
Jesus is sinless he's cleansed of any
sin he has no sin whether intentional or
or or unintentional he is sinless while
Muhammad Muhammad has sins Maybe maybe
they're unintentional but he has sins
and he asks for forgiveness you said 100
times a day but the the Hadith says
about 70 times a day that he asked for
forgiveness of his sins so Muhammad is
full of sin that he asks for forgiveness
for while Jesus is sinless right okay
can I say what I want to say is that
correct partial partial and you want me
to tell you which one not yeah yeah what
what part of what you said earlier is
not correct yeah yeah you asked me what
a messiah is I for my understanding one
of the part is being cleansed and then
you took the cleansing to be sinless
intentional okay you know what who was
it out of you and me that said to be
cleansed of sin is what being is is what
he's cleansed simply said cleansed and
you added the sin part you know what
hold that thought hold that thought hold
that thought hold that thought I think
that I only and you asked me and I said
yeah you know hold that though it's okay
hold that though hold that I might be
wrong I might be wrong no a't no might
be it ain't no might be let's let's go
ahead let's have ourselves a good time
because we got receipts okay luckily I'm
recording this live luckily yeah you
know and so um I just want to see here
if our uh let's get this off whoops I
want to see how we do here hold on let
me just rewind a bit I'mma unplug so
don't say nothing yet okay okay oh it's
okay hold that though hold that I might
be wrong I might be wrong I only you
asked me what a messiah is I for my
forgiveness for times a day but the the
Hadith says about 70 times and you don't
backtrack you yeah yeah I'm focusing on
one part that's really yes while Jesus
is sinless and never ask Sammy okay
you're right so showing that Muhammad
sins as far as my understanding is yes
we believe the same the prophets all
right clear Sammy you believe that Jesus
is sinless right as far as my
understanding is yes okay is that you
saying yes Jesus is sinless obviously
but we talk about then just one second
just hold on a second so yes Jesus is
sinless let's let's see if we could go
further back to get your exact words
about what he what it means that he's uh
cleansed what is he cleansed of who said
sins you or me let's see believe be
clear just be clear Sammy you believe
that yeah of any sin my belief would
tell me yes he is
period not sin knowing it's
understandable you know but prophets are
the Messiah is free from sin Messiah
means to be cleansed to be cleaned and
then to be appointed to be cleansed yeah
what to be cleansed cleansed of what of
sin so the Messiah is free from sin was
that you yeah one more time cleansed of
what but you know what what else I said
right of sin yeah what to be cleansed
cleansed of what of sin you want to let
me can you let me say something you want
me to take Qui so you're the one who
said that the Messiah is cleansed of sin
right yeah okay so wasn't me putting
words in your mouth or misrepresenting
you so the Messiah Jesus is cleansed of
all sin while Muhammad have has some
sins that he has to repent of correct
the way you're wording it I I will I
disagree with the your wording of that
statement but again these aren't my
words these are yours you acknowledge
that Jesus was sin of all you said Jesus
yeah but you after that you said that
Muhammad sinned and had to forgive ask
for forgiveness a 100 times a day
intentionally you know that's the part
you're missing understanding I you know
what Sammy this isn't gonna last long if
you're this dishonest I need you to keep
up I'm not okay if you sin intentionally
that's a sin okay if you sin
unintentionally it's still a sin correct
of course all right so you're saying
Muhammad has sins unintentionally that
he asks for forgiveness for right he
could I don't know anything about that
though okay you know what all right let
me let me help you know it about let me
help you know about it chapter 48:2 hold
on on you need to know this you need to
know this because you said you don't
know about it you need to know this
chapter 48 verse two of the Quran it
says hold on let me just just pull this
up real quick here so that you know I
don't want you walking away from this
live stream not knowing you're going to
know okay what words you said chapter 48
ver2 this is what it says it says this
is Allah speaking to Muhammad that God
May forgive you your former and latter
sins and complete his blessing upon you
and guide you on the straight path so
Muhammad has former sins sins of the
past that Allah's forgiving him for and
sins that he will commit in the future
that Allah saying I've already forgiven
you for it right yeah he's a human being
you know obviously all right how can I
dis good so Muhammad has sins that he
asks for forgiveness for Jesus is
sinless correct no sins so if I say yes
so what does that mean is he a God don't
be afraid of the implications just
acknowled let's let's follow the logic
first let's not jump ahead let's just
follow the logic I believe Muhammad is a
human being peace be upon
him you know just like Jesus is is a
human being yeah Jesus is so so I need
you to answer this so so Muhammad has
sinned and Jesus is without sin correct
so the one other way I will look at is
he was anointed after being anointed
maybe he was L but before that he wasn't
thanks for coming do the way that I
would look at that is
maybe before you speak uh Somaya before
you speak hello yeah just one second one
second guys do you notice the lengths
and you guys see it every time we're
live you see it all the time you see the
lengths that Muslims go to to try to
demean Jesus so that he's not above
Muhammad they tried to think of a
scenario a way that Jesus is a sinner
when their own Quran and their own
meanings of Messiah and their own Hadith
point to Jesus being sinless and
completely pure and perfect they have to
demean Jesus in order to try to elevate
Muhammad so that Jesus isn't special
over Muhammad look at what they have to
do my God I stuck fly La man you guys W
man may God have mercy on y'all